[Musik]
washington dc fast täglich wird in der
hauptstadt amerikas ein mensch
erschossen
als sie ihn erschossen haben waren die
kugeln so stark seine augen sprangen
heraus
jugendliche schießen aufeinander
als ich das militär verlassen habe wurde
mir klar washington ist schlimmer als
ein kriegsgebiet
kinder geraten zwischen die fronten
sie haben angefangen zu schießen und
geworden was getroffen in der szene
rappi über die gewalt singen und selbst
gefährlich leben ergaben männer sind ich
habe freunde die im gefängnis sind
freunde dem grab sind
die korona pandemie hat die mordrate
noch weiter nach oben getrieben
[Musik]
seit einem jahr wohne ich in washington
ich will wissen warum waffengewalt hier
so zum alltag gehört und menschen
treffen die ständig damit konfrontiert
werden denn die gewalt ist auch in
meinem viertel allgegenwärtig ich bin
gerade auf dem nachhauseweg und hier ist
überall polizei die straße ist
abgesperrt es muss irgendwas schon
wieder passiert sein
später finde ich raus ein 18-jähriger
hat vier schüsse abgefeuert an einer
belebten kreuzung ein mann muss verletzt
ins krankenhaus
am nächsten tag bin ich auf dem weg zur
arbeit
ich weiß inzwischen insgesamt gab es in
der stadt am vortag 4 schießereien die
bilanz zwei tote vier verletzte alltag
in washington
in den usa wurden im vergangenen jahr
fast 21.000 menschen durch eine
schusswaffe getötet gut 40.000 verletzt
washington ist eine der städte mit dem
steilsten anstieg
wir beginnen die dreharbeiten für diesen
film am rande der hauptstadt nur gut 20
autominuten vom kapitol entfernt ein
einkaufszentrum im stadtteil south east
einem der ärmsten washington hier ist
die gewalt schon lange an der
tagesordnung meine kollegin annette und
ich sind verabredet mit einer großmutter
die um ihren enkel trauert
petra anderson ihr enkel dimitri wurde
erschossen
genau hier wo nur noch 111 letter das
foto an ihn erinnert
hier das ist er ich muss das wieder
festkleben
hierher zu kommen ist ein kraftakt für
metro bisher hat sie diesen ort gemieden
zu schmerzhaft dimitri war erst 23 jahre
alt
es hieß damals es waren insgesamt 13
schüsse
ein polizist kam von dort nach dem
zwölften schuss rannte er wird aber der
mörder ist entkommen die leiche lag dort
unbedeckt
das handy ist voller erinnerungen sie
zeigt uns ein video von dimitri
[Musik]
eine nachricht an die familie damals
wurde er zum ersten mal angeschossen
dimitri hatte immer wieder mit der
polizei zu tun metro erzählt uns von
diebstählen schwarzmarkt verkaufen warum
er erschossen wurde ermitteln gerade die
strafbehörden
als sie ihn erschossen haben war die
wucht der kugeln so stark ist glaubt
dass seine augen aus dem kopf sprangen
wie kann jemand so oft auf ihn schießen
nicht ein oder zwei mal sie haben ihm
sechsmal in den kopf geschossen
wir sind erschrocken wie nüchtern sie
die brutalität beschreibt distanziert
aus angst daran zu zerbrechen
während wir mit etwa sprechen kommt
zufällig eine frau vorbei die sie noch
von früher kennt sie wohnt um die ecke
und hat an dem nachmittag die schüsse
gehört plötzlich teilte ihre eigene
geschichte
mein sohn ist vor zwei jahren gestorben
nicht hier da drüben im anderen viertel
du weißt ja wie das hier ist
auch diese frau erzählt vom tod ihres
sohnes fast wie nebenbei viel später
wird uns klar dass es eine form von
selbstschutz ist
ich weiß genau wie du dich fühlst
metro ist am ende ihrer kräfte wir
bieten an sie nach hause zu bringen ihre
wohnung ist in einem ghetto in dem nur
schwarze leben weiße nicht leben wollen
wer hier wohnt kommt gerade mal so über
die runden die armut ist bedrückend wir
wollen nie drei wiedertreffen mehr von
ihrem leben erfahren aber erst mal
müssen auch wir diesen tag revue
passieren lassen
sind man hat fast den eindruck als würde
manchmal so eine spannung in der luft
liegen und das müsste man schon auch
schauen dass man nicht zu lange dort
rumhängt und filmt jeder guckt um die
ecke jeder achte darauf was um einen
herum passiert also ich glaube schon
dass dieses gefühl dass da irgendwas in
der luft liegt auch echt und das geht
nicht nur uns so sondern alle merken wir
sind hier in der öffentlichkeit hier
kann jederzeit passieren
wir wollen verstehen wieso tödliche
waffen so alltäglich sind unsere
recherche führt uns in die rap kultur wo
möchtegern gangster schnelles geld und
tödliche waffen glorifizieren
enger tod heims ist als einziger aus der
szene bereit mit uns zu sprechen
er will uns seine welt zeigen wieder
ärmliche verhältnisse aus denen er nie
rausgekommen ist
wie war das hier aufzuwachsen
völlig verrückt du musst die ganze zeit
aufpassen wo immer du hingehst wir
ständig was los vor den kameras kann ich
gar nicht davon sprechen
du kannst vor den kameras nicht darüber
sprechen
ja das geht gar nicht
er hat selbst familie eine frau und zwei
kinder im viertel kennt ihn jeder
nur deshalb ist es sicher genug für uns
und auch für ihn mit der kamera hier
entlang zu laufen
einschusslöcher in den bänden vernagelte
fenster ich frage ihn wieso geschossen
wird drogen gang kriminalität aber es
ist viel profaner
es kann alles mögliche los sein streit
mit seiner familie streit mit seinen
feinden damit musst du leben
es ist ganz einfach pass auf dich auf
wenn du hier draußen bist und achtet
genau darauf was um dich herum passiert
muss ständig wachsam sein deswegen habe
ich auch gesagt dass es besser ist hier
steht nicht so lange hier draußen rum
hast du schon mal selbst in
schwierigkeiten groß na klar ich war ein
kind und jedes kind kriegt mal ärger es
geht darum wie du damit umgeht hast du
selbst eine waffe
habe ich nicht ich habe keinen
waffenschein
wenn ich den habe werde ich mir eine
waffe holen wenn mir jemand schaden will
kann ich ihm auch schaden meine freunde
sitzen im gefängnis manche sind im grab
ich versuche nicht böse zu sein ich will
für meine kinder da sein
er wirkte als wolle er heute das
richtige tun auch wenn das bedeutet sich
mit gelegenheitsjobs durchzuschlagen von
seiner musik leben kann er nicht
hinter den fassaden dieser häuser hätten
viele ihre eigenen waffen das weiß
natürlich auch er
wir finden niemanden der mit uns darüber
redet das ist doch klar sie können über
so etwas nicht in aller öffentlichkeit
reden jeder der darüber spricht macht
sich strafbar verstehst du
das dürfen die gar nicht zu geben sonst
könnten sie doch gleich zur polizei
gehen und sagen ich war's sperrt mich
ein
länger kennt die regeln dieser welt hat
darin seinen platz gefunden
wer aus der armut der
perspektivlosigkeit ausbrechen will hat
nicht viele möglichkeiten
kriminelle geschäfte versprechen
schnelles geld ob das schafft zu
widerstehen wir werden ihn wieder
treffen
wie kann ein ausweg aus dieser
alltäglichen gewalt aussehen
in den ghettos der stadt kann es tödlich
enden einfach zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort zu sein
auch kinder geraten immer wieder
zwischen die fronten ausgerechnet in den
usa einem der mächtigsten wohlhabendsten
länder der welt mit jede stunde ein kind
angeschossen oder erschossen
giovanna hds sozialarbeiterin sie
versucht kinder und jugendliche
fernzuhalten von dieser gefahr und zu
verhindern dass sie selbst zur waffe
greifen
anstatt sich zu prügeln oder sauer zu
wählen
aber erst mal tief durch
entspannungsübungen sport das alles sind
kurze trostpflaster
und es ist ein kraftakt die kinder
überhaupt zusammen zu halten es geht
chaotisch zu wir merken dass viele hier
keine ruhe keine stabilität kennen
wir fahren mit giovanna in ihr büro
mitten in der stadt mittwochs
organisiert sie dort eine art
abendschule
im klassenraum kehrt endlich so etwas
wie ruhe ein
[Musik]
wie gefallen euch die abende mit
misshandlungen suisse hardy wenn wir mit
miss hardy hier sind führen wir uns
sicher weil sie waffen gewalt nicht mal
bei menschen ihr leben verlieren
jeden tag werden kinder
mein kumpel ist erst vor zwei tagen
angeschossen worden
ich glaube
wie alt war er
13 ist er im krankenhaus hieß er ja er
hat überlebt
nur wer von euch kennt jemanden der
erschossen wurde
[Musik]
also ihr alle brüder freunde
manche von uns haben auch ihren vater
verloren
es fehlt an allem geld ablenkung guten
schulen psychologischer und sozialer
hilfe
[Musik]
hier dürfen sie für zwei drei stunden
einfach kinder seien so wie ich das
kindsein kenne ausgelassen fröhlich sie
sind mir sehr sympathisch aber ich weiß
auch dass sie in ihrem alltag jederzeit
sowohl opfer als auch täter werden
können
du hast mir erzählt dass einer seiner
jungs ein zehnjähriges kind eine waffe
mit zur schule gebracht hat woher hat
ein zehnjähriger eine waffe
das liegt an den nachbarschaften es ist
gefährlich auch nur draußen herum zu
laufen du kannst zur zielscheibe werden
familien müssen sich schützen um sich
sicher zu fühlen und eine waffe bedeutet
sicher
aber waffen werden nicht immer an einem
sicheren ort aufbewahrt und dadurch
haben kinder zu
ghana war lange beim militär vor vier
jahren gründete sie ihre initiative
gegen waffengewalt
als ich die armee verließ wurde mir klar
washington ist schlimmer als manches
kriegsgebiet
washington ist natürlich kein
kriegsgebiet aber ich verstehe dass
diese kinder eine ähnliche angst
empfinden
ich lebe in einer stadt in der oft schon
kinder und jugendliche kriminell werden
die schützen immer jünger werden
in washington gab es im vergangenen jahr
227 tote bei schießerei so viele wie
seit 18 jahren nicht mehr
darüber wollen wir mit der polizei
sprechen
die hat unsere anfragen wochen lang
ignoriert wir erfahren von einem
nachbarschaftstreffen polizei
hausverwaltung und anwohner wollen ins
gespräch kommen weil auch hier immer
wieder geschossen wird aber bevor es
überhaupt losgehen kann plötzlich diese
nachricht
gerade gab es wieder zwei schießereien
eine erst vor zehn minuten
ein junger mann wurde in den kopf
geschossen das hat jetzt vorhanden
wir können kaum fassen dass wir schon
wieder so nah in einer schießerei sind
überall wo wir hingehen kein zufall
glaubt auch hausverwalter brian
mcloughlin
gegen korona waren wir alle eingesperrt
da hat sich frust angestaut depressionen
angst und
manche menschen werden dadurch
aggressiver und wütender
deswegen sehen wir auch einen deutlichen
anstieg an waffengewalt dass gerade
heute so etwas passiert ist einfach nur
traurig
deshalb wollen sie an diesem nachmittag
präsenz zeigen signalisieren dass sie
gewalt hier nicht tolerieren
den polizisten dürfen wir keine fragen
stellen wir laufen mit ihnen durch diese
anlage die dem anschein nach ein
studentenwohnheim sein könnte der schein
trügt der kinderspielplatz ist ganz neu
aber benutzen können die kinder ihn nur
selten
es ist eine schande was hier los ist und
keiner tut etwas dagegen
das ist auch der grund warum viele
anwohner nicht aus ihren häusern
rauskommen oder ihre kinder nicht
rauslassen sie haben angst das verstehe
ich kugeln haben keine augen
loretta carey lebt seit mehr als 30
jahren bier sie fordert mehr
polizeipräsenz
so kann die polizei helfen
wenn du sie ruft kommen sie aber
sie können ja nicht an fünf orten
gleichzeitig sein
meistens kommen sie erst nach dem etwas
passiert ist
man kann ja nicht vorher schon wissen
wann etwas passieren wird
immerhin kameras wurden inzwischen
installiert hier hilft das erklären die
polizisten aber die schießereien
verhindern dass können die kameras nicht
die laufen einfach nachgeben
wir können waffen nicht verhindern
höchstens das verhalten so dass menschen
keine waffen mehr benutzen
die schießereien verlagern sich ins
viertel nebenan wo es keine kameras gibt
dort können wir nicht mehr filmen für
uns ist es zu gefährlich
es dauerte wochen bis wir endlich ein
interview mit der polizei washingtons
bekommen wir sind verabredet mit dem
stellvertretenden polizeichef
er hat nur 15 minuten für uns ein enger
zeitplan die polizei in washington ist
unterbesetzt
ich kriege jeden tag meldungen von
schießereien bis das der grund warum sie
so viel zu tun haben
absolut jeden tag werden schießereien
gemeldet und die polizei geht jeder
dieser meldungen nach wir versuchen so
schnell wie möglich vor ort zusammen
es mache ihm sorgen dass die schützen
immer jünger die schießereien immer mehr
werden
woran liegt das spielt
da kommt viel zusammen
als george freud vor einigen jahren
getötet wurde hat das dem ansehen der
polizei sehr geschadet
und dann kam auch noch wir hatten
weniger polizisten auf der straße das
wurden weniger stellen
die zusammenarbeit mit den
polizeibehörden war nicht gut das wird
zwar gerade wieder ein bisschen besser
aber wir müssen noch viel vertrauen
zurück
nur wenige tage nach unserem interview
mit der polizei komme ich auf meinem
nachhauseweg wieder zufällig an einem
tatort vorbei meine wohnung gleich um
die ecke
zwei jugendliche haben in der
metrostation aufeinandergeschossen einer
muss schwer verletzt ins krankenhaus
je länger wir an diesem film arbeiten
desto wohler fühle ich mich ich fange an
die metrostation zu meiden gleichzeitig
ist mir bewusst ich kann mich entziehen
viele andere nicht wir fahren noch
einmal zu nitra deren enkel dimitri
erschossen wurde wollen wissen wie sie
mit diesem schweren verlust klarkommt
sie hat uns eingeladen ihre wohnungen
der alles an dimitri erinnert schau mal
da oben alles
heute kümmert sich nicht um seine kinder
das sind seine kinder ich werde mich um
seine babys kümmern
gott hat mich hier behalten und er hatte
seinen grund die kinder sind der grund
wir holen mit mithras tochter la bonne
die kinder vom kindergarten ab und
müssen dabei durch eine gefährliche
gegend wie gehst du mit all dem um
das ist schwierig für mich
es passiert so oft in dieser gegend aber
wenn es dir selbst passiert ist das
definitiv was anderes
es wird real
legte eine patronenhülse
eine patronenhülse schau hier
die habe ich gar nicht gesehen
fast täglich wird hier geschossen als la
bonne die kinder abholt haben wir einen
moment zeit die ereignisse sacken zu
lassen
es regt zum nachdenken an finde ich also
alles wie es wie sie damit umgeht und
ich finde es auch diese kurze wegstrecke
hier
also dass wir in schulweg haben auf dem
kugeln rumliegen
dimitris kinder sind erst vier und fünf
jahre alt die normalität dieser szene
ist trügerisch
während im hintergrund der eiswagen
seine melodie spielt merken wir dass die
stimmung kippt wie er aus den
umliegenden häusern beobachtet werden
es ist gefährlich hier lang zu laufen
das war
jetzt gerade
also sollten wir nicht so lange hier
draußen sein nicht zu lange
schwarze männer wie dimitri sterben in
washington im durchschnitt 17 jahre
früher als weiße neben der waffengewalt
gibt es noch andere gründe
die sehen wir bei unseren fahrten durch
die armenviertel hier ist die
gesundheitsversorgung schlecht frische
lebensmittel mangelware genau wie gute
schulen die ghettos sind durch
jahrhundertelange
ungerechtigkeiten entstanden
struktureller rassismus
viele menschen sind vom system abgehängt
die folge häufig alkoholismus
drogenmissbrauch kriminalität und eine
spirale der gewalt
waffen sind in den usa leicht zu
bekommen zum beispiel in shops wie
diesem nur zehn autominuten von der
stadtgrenze washingtons entfernt
pistolen für die nachttischschublade
halbautomatische waffen maschinengewehre
mit hunderten schuss pro minute
break zeigt uns seine aussage
warum kaufen menschen solche waffen
zur selbstverteidigung
was muss man vorweisen um so eine waffe
zu kaufen
man muss seinen führerschein vorzeigen
und ein formular aus
dann mache ich ein hintergrund check
wenn der positiv ist kann man die waffe
noch am gleichen tag mit nach hause
nehmen
in washington sind die waffengesetze
etwas strenger eine halbautomatische
waffe wie diese wäre nicht erlaubt
als er mir die erste pistole in die hand
gibt wird mir klar wie viel schief gehen
kann ich habe keine ahnung worauf ich
achten muss ja es gibt nie mit der waffe
auf jemand muss ihren und finger weg vom
abzug
okay aber die waffe es nicht geladen
oder
richtig aber auch wenn sie nicht geladen
ist musst du sie so behandeln als wäre
sie geladen ich hatte noch nie eine
waffe der hand
die nächste die er mir gibt es wirklich
überall erlaubt auch in washington
achte auf den vorderen teil dafür
braucht man schon muskeln in den armen
man braucht natürlich nicht besonders
viele muskeln trotzdem zittern meine
arme
michael interessiert sich für eine neun
millimeter
er hat gerade seinen waffenschein
gemacht
wofür brauchst du die in erster linie
zum schutz ich wollte mal schauen was
sie hier so haben damit ich mich zu
hause ordentlich schützen kann
warum brauchst du zu hause eine waffe
es kann ziemlich verrückt so gehen in
manchen gegenden den meisten leuten
vertraue ich nicht also aus
sicherheitsgründen
waffen zu kaufen und zu besitzen ist ein
teil amerikanischer realität und kultur
350 millionen schusswaffen in
privatbesitz gibt es mehr als einwohner
innen und das ist nur der legale teil
unendlich viele waffen werden illegal
weiterverkauft
so ganz wohl hast du nicht dicht gefüllt
mit der waffe in der hand nämlich ganz
schrecklich also es war ein ganz
komisches gefühl und gleichzeitig finde
ich hat hat es aber auch so normal
gemacht dass man die dort einfach so
erwerben konnte und in die hand nehmen
konnte er hat mit einer ruhe und mit
einer selbstverständlichkeit über dieses
thema gesprochen wo dann vielleicht auch
deutlich wird das für ganz ganz viele
amerikaner das thema waffen auch nicht
diese emotionalität hat die wir oftmals
damit verbinden also das ist mir bei
wels gefangen ich hatte auch das gefühl
wir kommen aus vollkommen
unterschiedlichen welten für mich gibt
es keinen grund warum man eine
halbautomatische waffe oder ein
maschinengewehr zum beispiel braucht
die gewalt ist längst nicht mehr nur ein
problem der armen viertel am stadtrand
washingtons sie schwarz auch in die
hippen szene viertel im zentrum über wo
sie für privilegierte menschen wie mich
erst sichtbar geworden ist
curtis mozy erlebt diese gewalt seit
fast 30 jahren
sein haus ist eine art museum in dem er
dokumentiert wie viele seiner freunde
pro jahr erschossen wurden
hier hängt ein bild für jeden freund den
ich verloren habe bitte namen und dem
jahr als er starb
von 1980 bis
dieses jahr waren es acht menschen das
ist irre gedenkstätte
früher war das hier ein safe house ein
ort wo jugendliche aus der gegend hin
kamen um spaß zu haben wo sie sicher
waren bei körpers herrschte
waffenstillstand heute sind die kinder
der männer an der wand so alt wie ihre
väter als sie erschossen wurden
es wird immer schlimmer
ihre eltern hatten bessere chancen
es gibt immer mehr waffen und die
bereitschaft sie einzusetzen
jahrzehnte lang filmte er die jungs die
zu ihm kamen erst aus spaß aber
irgendwann wurde es bitterer ernst wenn
sie erschossen wurden machte könntest
daraus filme zur erinnerung für ihre
familie
er dokumentierte sogar ihren tod es sind
aufnahmen die ich kaum ertragen kann
eine familie im krankenhaus ein bruder
schwer verletzt
[Musik]
musste fast weinen als ich mir die
bilder angeschaut habe wie geht es dir
dabei
das war schwer aber ich muss das machen
für die familien der man möchte weil
aber genau das brauchen wir weil niemand
weil
[Musik]
auch das kennen wir doch daran bin ich
gewöhnt ist doch nur ein schwarzer mann
nein nein nein das ist ein mensch der
von jemandem geliebt wurde das macht es
real
könnte mein bruder sein das ist nicht
nur eine nummer ganz genau deswegen
mache ich das hier aber
irgendwann hielt auch goethes dass viele
leid nicht mehr aus die diagnose seines
psychiaters
posttraumatisches stresssyndrom eine
diagnose wie sie in der szene wohl viele
hören würden aber hilfe suchen die
wenigsten viele sind von der gewalt auf
den straßen oder in der eigenen familie
traumatisiert
[Musik]
sie betreuten sich mit alkohol oder
drogen oder werden selbst gewalttätig
wieso müssen menschen wie curtis bis zur
selbstaufopferung kämpfen die
unterstützt die stadt dabei diese fragen
beschäftigen uns schon seit einer weile
aber unsere interviewanfragen werden
abgelehnt wir fahren spontan von einer
pressekonferenz
bürgermeisterin marion browser steht
unter druck ihre umfragewerte sind im
sinkflug
ich habe eine frage an die
bürgermeisterin die menschen haben angst
vor der steigenden kriminalität und
washington ihre zustimmungswerte fall
tut die stadt genug
wie ich gerade gesagt habe die zahl der
morde und autodiebstähle ist gestiegen
und die menschen wollen dass ihre
bürgermeisterin etwas dagegen tun
wir suchen nach neuen partnerschaften
und sehen uns jede städtische programm
genau an um sicherzugehen dass es
funktioniert
was nicht funktioniert lösen der auf
lippenbekenntnisse keine konkreten
lösungsansätze wir versuchen es noch
einmal
wie will die politik gezielt gewalt
verhindern aber wir bekommen keine
genaueren antworten die stadt wirkt
hilflos im umgang mit der waffengewalt
[Musik]
wir besuchen noch einmal länger tot als
er will es schaffen aus der
perspektivlosigkeit der armut muss sich
aber selbst einen weg suchen
kriminalität verspricht schnelles geld
aber wenger will widerstehen jeder müsse
eine entscheidung treffen darüber singt
er
was sind das für entscheidungen
es geht darum welche entscheidungen
triffst stell dir vor ein kumpel kommt
zu mir geklaut mich
das finde ich nicht gut
du musst entscheidungen treffen
auch er trifft jeden tag aufs neue eine
entscheidung sagt er er schreibt täglich
songs diesen hatte erst am morgen
geschrieben
hält es sich auch von ärger verwies auf
jeden fall euro ist genial und weißt du
wieso ich bin immer im haus du wirst
mich nie draußen sehen
nur wenn ich auf dem weg zum studio
binden
wer am haus bleibt ist sicher wer eine
beschäftigung hat ist sicher das
erinnert mich an curtis' safe house
bangert heims will dass die welt seine
songs vom leben im ghetto hört
mit dem rappen berühmt werden das kommt
mir vor wie ein sechser im lotto aber es
zeigt wie wenige chancen viele hier
haben
[Musik]
wir treffen netra ein letztes mal sie
ist auf dem friedhof es ist jedes mal
ein schwerer gang für sie hier liegt ihr
enkel dimitri begraben für einen
grabstein das geld bisher nicht gereicht
das einzig gute daran ist ich muss mir
keine sorgen mehr machen dimitri ist
erlöst
aber diese stadt ist die hölle
washington ist die
es klingt für mich fast als hätte sie
mit ihrem eigenen leben schon
abgeschlossen doch dann frage ich sie
nach dimitris kindern ihren urenkeln
glaubst du dass die kinder es einmal
besser haben werden oder hast du sorge
dass die spirale der gewalt nie aufhört
ich muss bei ihnen bleiben als er
beschützen
sie müssen lernen waffen wir haben keine
waffen zu hause
eine waffe hat mir meinen enkel genommen
wir spielen nicht mit waffen
am anfang habe ich mir die frage
gestellt wieso die waffengewalt so zum
amerikanischen alltag gehört die antwort
das weiß ich jetzt es kompliziert
erdrückender armut rassismus oder eine
gewaltspirale die sich seit generationen
immer weiter dreht das macht es menschen
wie dimitri und banger so schwer zu
entkommen der kampf gegen die tödliche
waffen gewalt es scheint ein kampf zu
sein der kaum zu gewinnen ist